how you doing bud
good evening gentlemen uh good evening
sir honorable rich thanks for uh stephen
um
anyways let me dive right into it so
gentlemen um
i thought i broke up with my ex
uh about a month ago and she has
exhibited many of the i'm gonna say like
17 of the red flags
and then over the time i was like god
this chicken this ain't the one so i
finally listened to myself
and i left the situation
but
so recently her mom passed away
and i was like damn like so there's this
part of me that's like yo
you should reach out to her and try to
help her out but
i've tried to help her out in the past
okay okay stop stop stop stop stop stop
because i mean you're talking about
playing captain sabah with a check
that's got 17 red flags
how long how long did you date this one
for
i dated this girl for three years
and
like when did the red flags start to
show up was it month one was it a you
know month 36
uh when i look back on it i'm gonna say
like six seven months and my ass was
like
i had this picture of this girl in my
head and i just kept hoping you're fully
invested though at that point
yeah your boyfriend girlfriend you're
gonna be together forever and ever until
kingdom come blah blah blah right
yeah i've recently tried to break out of
this nice guy [ __ ] and uh yeah
have any no more mr nice guy
excuse me have you read no more mr nice
guy
i have i have yeah okay so you know all
about the covert contracts
yeah yeah okay i was playing that game
and i was like god this dude is reading
me like a book like explaining me to a
team
so you have to you have to connect with
a little bit of your inner [ __ ] you
know to what amount is you know up to
you but there's a little dial within
every guy
you know that
at some point somebody somewhere or it
usually comes from women he that's an
athol i hate him right it's like okay
maybe the dial needs to go up a little
bit more because you need to hear that a
little bit more often or maybe you've
never heard it in your life you need to
crank it right up
right
but there's a part of you that's like
too nice and too accommodating it's like
you know i want to i want to go and
serve this chick that was a nightmare in
my life for three years to go to some
funeral of somebody that's not even in
your family
yeah yeah that's true
right so why do you like to torture
yourself let's start with that question
oh man um that's what i'm trying to
pivot away from now sir uh
you know learn behavior from the past
and look family family dynamic
i'm really starting to see it all and
i'm like yo
i mean like we just had that lady on
michelle and she's like don't deal with
crazy
right she's got daughters i mean
hopefully she tells her daughters you
know
don't be crazy
hey no i thought i found your content
about
around six months ago
and then that's when i started i was
like whoa
oh [ __ ]
uh yeah this is this is explaining her t
as well so yeah a lot of people have
that reaction
yeah um yeah just look dude just accept
it surrender to it this is female nature
there's some good ones and there's some
bad ones
and you know as you go about your life
and you're chasing excellence and you
engage with women you're you just have
to get good at spotting the ones that
are going to be you know dangerous in
your life it's the same thing with dudes
like you know if you had a guy in your
life that would continuously borrow
money show up late
uh
make a mess of your bathroom when he's
over he just pisses and shits everywhere
like just a total train wreck would you
keep inviting this guy into your house
no no
right but as soon as a girl looks pretty
and smells nice and she touches your pee
pee all of a sudden you forget about all
those red flags
standards man it's just you know just
raise your standards with women right
like hold yourself to higher standards
expect more out of them
yes sir
and you know crazy like i went out i
went i was
saving saving this chick all this time
and then i finally ended things
um
she completely
it was like the last part it was like yo
she said all this [ __ ] about me and i
was like damn
damn for real is that what we is that
what you got from this relationship got
you
though but that soft spot was like damn
her mom just died i was cool with her i
thought she would and that was the part
that's me like maybe i need to go not go
back to her what are the words trey what
are the words that come after complicate
life
you haven't you haven't watched enough
of my videos or read my book then
complicate life justify why this is what
men love to do with their lives
right
it's like i'll see a box it'll say red
flags on it i'll look in the box i'll
see a whole bunch of red flags in it but
i'm going to date it for six months
anyway
even though you know what you're getting
into right that's what men love to do
complicate life justify why ask yourself
when you're doing things especially with
women is this going to unnecessarily
complicate my life
all right
all right brother i'm going to let you
go because a little bit of background
noise hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you